[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors j'avoue d un peu difficile de
passer après une très belle histoire
sinon tant qu'
il a expliqué qu'en est-il passé tout
à la suite de cela on fait une
présentation
et tu dois venir relever ce défi je
pense que tous apprennent partie de ce
revirement
est là pour laquelle je suis devant vous
ce soir
[Musique]
pour ceux qui connaissent le jeu
d'échecs le client qui porte la couronne
est le plus petit pion bechikh
récipient avec deux bordées d'arbres
parce de finale lorsqu'il arrive a
rejoint le canadien a laissé ses petits
bords des sept bourses
et donc ce soir j'aimerais vivre une
cuisson en cendres et les amène une
sortie d'ici chacun de nous puisse avoir
une comme je pense que l'allemagne est
déjà présent
ensemble nous avons essayé de saisir nos
coûts
alors
je me suis rendu compte au fil du temps
[Musique]
avec les situations de j'ai traversé
tout le monde mal surtout sur le plan
médical il ya une grosse vente qui ont
fait que j'ai écrit dans le dos d'âne et
par la cie râpé damas dont un âgé lui
quand même équilibré mais mon âme et des
phases i et
donné tellement de
défis à enlever
notamment les défis la force je vous
assure que pendant
quinze ans de magie de chaleur le vent
le même poids en petit bassin on te
reconnaît pascal venger des menaces la
marge était par
exemple demandé beaucoup d'efforts de
conseillère je veux qu'on te vois tu le
fais sortie des bus
présenter les eaux sales
les femmes aussi
mais cela demandait beaucoup d'efforts
et fut que ce combat de la france
devenait compliqué j'ai décidé de me
lire no comment sud du sahara
et lunettes chose d'y attirer
l'attention sur nous et diageo
si vous remarquez ce point fermé
l'éléphant du monde de l'art ancien et
l'art ans enrage nous faire marrer ces
différentes alors qu'ils sont sûrs
main très souvent ce soir et alors que
les vaines recherches
déjections il s'agit de montrer
et je me suis demandé comment se fait il
que lorsque en sommes là tout le monde
te regarde
et ne fera pas forcément ses tableaux et
3 qui sera signée rend précieux s'étend
de l'appareil et dont j'ai fait une
petite recherche concernant l'avs et je
me suis rendu compte que la mère
allaitant original et en 02 et 1 mm mais
sous pression dû augmenter autant d afin
de faciliter le flux de sang parce que
la paix pour ceux qui ne le savent pas
pour moi ne savait pas ce résultat net
par lequel le sens mois pour que
d'entendre commencer à voir le coeur qui
bat très vite
il ya un profit de frontier 2
j'ai juste à rome et dans notre pays car
elle nous permet de savoir mais nous
sommes vous perdez décemment que le
sorte d'ami et que nous devons bouger
alors je suis dit c'est 500
ordinateurs
je vis des traits
pour moi ce que je ne serai pas le
danois en ligue 1 le monde prépare
le coeur de membres et pas
si je n'étais pas là pour parce que mon
prochain canal par lequel
m
or si nous acceptons et c'est pas mal de
nous serons demande ce canard avec l
unil hommage
ou alors quelque chose de nouveau
viendrait pansement il y aussi vous
pourrez décider par nous supermarché de
monde
aujourd'hui lorsque nous parlons d
exemple
les inopinés
alors parlons de la
petite le chp tiges yeux
que je suis graphiste j'aime bien jouer
avec
les images et les mots et donc pour la
fête je me suis dit le premier est ici
le
[Musique]
berry et vendez
quel look
3 voir ici en marge de ces la vision
ce rapport balisés
trois thèmes des objectifs tout cela les
piétons
il est maintenant temps de télévision
plutôt que de regarder ce qui se passe
autour
pas
[Musique]
je les fais dans ma maison j'ai
vision c'était à défaut
ça
les richesses
c'est magique et aujourd'hui encore plus
dont changeant le combat
avec mac ne sont pas les nôtres et
des difficultés l'impression
[Musique]
alors
recherche vision qui soit a beaucoup de
matches et un terme aux angoisses et
pour arras
à la barre alors sitôt en conclusion
se doter de deux états
un état d'esprit un suspens qui va nous
permettre de moins de vous devez
chapelet d'îles qui se présentera
apparemment à la pression d'un que son
ventre
quel est ton état d'esprit
pourquoi cette question chaque matin je
t'aime moi
non je me dois la bande état d'esprit
que le dernier travaux devra surmonter
toutes les épouses sont présentement à
temps et a descendu au fond elle n'est
pas déçue mais le terme l état décide de
vous flinguer
sébum
télévision même vision c'est bien il
faut avoir l'état d'esprit qui partage
la plupart le constat fait tous ceux qui
souhaiteraient
en prix mais a du mal tant
provisionnement objectifs annuels ils
ont demandé d'aller suivre son
traitement il existe mais tous ceux qui
veulent faire du bien
ils ont plus tard et a détruit la
solidité partie fois les procès dans ce
look moins de sauvetage plutôt que les
solutions ou la souscription par passer
l'obstacle
et on s'est créé des occasions et un bon
état d'esprit ce qui sera important pour
toi c'est un membre des tensions
qu'elles en dépensent
pour moi ce que tu es gay
à cette question personnellement je me
suis dit écoute on parle de plusieurs
personnes dans d'histoire des vallées du
bees nous a parlé des stickers
tout ça
jusqu'aujourd'hui
par
ces personnes que moi j'ai affronté les
guette un exemple moite et un modèle qui
continuent d'être
ces pompes et il mon père lorsque
j'observe barbeau je m'étais dit tiens
je n'ai pas besoin d'autre chose de voix
et si j'essaie de l'équitation que
j'aime alors je pourrais la peine
et donc mon intention de pouvoir réussir
en résidence de création
j'ai eu pas besoin je me suis branché
n'est pas exclue pour avancer et je me
suis
et vous savez quoi ce qui est bien un
ange là c'est que tu te donne une bonne
intention c'est que forcément
les idées des pâtissiers temps de la
caisse que t'importe si j'aime bien des
papilles ce que tu veux atteint 6
défaites et qui sont clairement définis
c'est sûr que là quotidiennement alors
d'une amende aux est d'aller de l'avant
de courant bousculé par l'union comme
une honte il explique un résident de
pouvoir mantenir ne paie pas le pouvoir
les déplacements on ne pouvait pas
penser de ne pas pouvoir monter et c'est
cela la nouveauté vous de décider de
couloirs du parlement dans mon
environnement et qui saura que tu crées
par une solution
by
pierre bel exploit
mais imaginez un instant
tu as une vision
car mon état d'esprit
de contrainte
jamais d'idées novatrices que pour mon
diary
est fait par mois
hachey
a remis le 2 mai par des médias mais
tout est d'y faire face allégé de
ce que j'ai appris et de ce que j'ai
contré de
l'échec
l'échec n'est pas une banalité ses 20 de
canal
si je décide de partir sans pendant
contre l'échec que lorsqu'il se
présentera à bord du sun
[Musique]
sea dont nombreuses constructions
camions les défaillances du coup vers
l'est alors à anticiper cette falaise
alors trouvera à aller de l'avant pour
moi par contre c'est que leur chemin des
chênes bras même si tu n'as pas la
solution immédiate ou même je n'ai pas
la solution
à chaque échec qui sait cependant qu'il
existe un autre chemin pour atteindre
l'objectif étant tu chercheras ne
bougera plus pratique pour un titre en
jeu vous racontez lui disent partout
mais personne pour l image rénale pour
représenter le pilote de formule 1 pour
moi c'est bien
et l'année dernière lors de la ronde
finale
il était ajusteur quel point tu secondes
tout se passe bien jusqu'au dernier tour
j'étais entraîneur dimanche j'étais brno
et je suis l archos ou nantes et saint
jacques faty qui dansent un tour chez
moi est attaqué tous y gagnent 6 gagnés
l'oreille us son métier a trouvé une
équipe de grands pilotes d'efforts
juste avant le drame et tout à l'avant
dernier tour bill accident kahyasi
d'ensorcellement sécurité tout je parle
là que passionné de formule 1
gérard est vrai
parce que pour moi j'aime bien ce pont
est donc agir dans votre exposé voiture
sécurité tout arrosé ralenti tout le
monde la zone où
ils font le premier tour de sécurité et
au dernier tour
on n'est ce pas ce que c'est qu'un
retard selon
les consignes habituelles états membres
y sont censés ferrand toponymie le du
temps et puis ensuite on ne le dit pas
mais c'est moi si tu n'as plus l'image
détour s'ils le font c'est que 80 et
100 secondes qui est le potentiel humain
que ziaya bull si le fond du dernier
tour sera so what et des civils --dont
me gilles jean pierre
30 août par
la direction du sport décide de retirer
la matinée celui des mines et on la
bataille durant le dernier tour
pourquoi je devais par l'islam par an
derrière ce dernier qui a réussi à
adapter par chacune des écuries les
puits de celui déjà existant a décidé de
le laisser en vie parce qu'on saisit la
pesée a terminé la seconde était ville a
décidé de faire rentrer la voiture vous
changez vous sentir tout lors qu'ils
vous prennent
forcément dans la bataille le champion
tout des désavantages ici en apparence
pour préserver
absolument
d'immenses pans égard le championnat
tout devient vous la première fois dans
son histoire des deux ans mais ils
deviennent chanter la déception
que j'ai eu à son
tour a lieu ce jeudi à tonnerre chez eux
je suis en pyjama l'état round après
dissidente de gueye la vallée du lot à
face à l'émoi
provoqué par l'accident la réunion gdir
bull mène et a même réussi gigot
d'agneau et une île après des pertes
mais loin de leur
pays moi une rivière dans déjà des
membres comment
2010la revue qui pourra pas traiter
vraiment tiré de piloter cet échec est
une leçon pour lui des sondés lui afin
d'améliorer leurs amis dans cette
période pour le championnat de la
dentition et donc sans mais la régie au
delà le touriste rageant
102 dont le rejet des deux barreurs plus
parce que là à la bouche heures dans la
même promo
et en tenant
compte du magazine lors que tu n as pas
sûr même si je t'assure contribuer
au renforcement de l'ailé et décidé
d'aller de l'avant dans la réalité
l'échec ce n'est pas une fin d'année
viennent au compte d'un blessé
meilleur temps pour ceux qui
décideraient du suivant patinoire
même quand
j'ai parlé de cela si vous avez remarqué
plus nous avons pris
le pari là et la great et en d'autres
termes on note et a descendu que nous
soyons une époque où que nous soyons ne
se sera continuera d'y faire son travail
jusqu'à rue duquesne avait tenté le
coeur fonctionne à la 21e et pourtant
c'est l'imprévu libérer pour que
fonctionne d'autant que charles ne sera
pas le monde sera toujours mais leur
nombre serait bien sympa à partir de ce
moment nous devons arrêter avec des
problèmes
évitez et je termine ont été surpassées
belle frappe détournée dans le village
et se réinventer de nicole paulo qui dit
ce rayon d avoir une bourre à le
transcender ses peurs ses talents de
meneur
seidou viennent de projets me dirai tout
en appréciant le moment réside tu ne
peux pas demander pour le futur de venir
vont parce que tu vas améliorer ce petit
tu devenir partenaire et le véhicule et
du développement parce que tu veux mais
celui-là d'abord à apporter une pierre à
l'édifice
bâti donc vous exemple jeunes à faire
j'avais vraiment positif et surtout pas
dans notre monde meilleur et
pouvoir de nouveau obligé si du bas rhin
ce qui en reste
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]